[音楽]
me
goo
ん
はいローワーで揚げ足とバター
販売中止になりました
すー
僕ですね販売中心である少し1週間前ぐらいにヤングを
集めたつ個人的に
宇宙神ないとは知らなくて純正にこういちファンとして普通に集めたんですよ
多分目ちょい足りないのがあると思うんですけどもちょ手に入る軍の全種類のペヤング
を手に入れました
見たことがないですよこれまず普通の脳なるペンですこれはみんな知ってると思います
ガーリック醤油です
ハーフ&ハーフのカレー焼きそば野麦側です
図中バー御用達の激辛行きそばや基礎は極み
ペンでエヴィゾはですや基礎が根岸おくもん
んじゃ風味結構リアルの方でたぶん5珍しいピンクなんですけど一人が遊びに来てるん
で
今日は提案での本当にも頂点に君臨する
みんなで食べようと思ってもうぜひに混ぜます大
結局一番美味しいな全部混ぜるんだよ
なじゃあな
時はみんなでねペヤングを混ぜて言ってああ
を楽しみましょうよくして立ち会わせ移動全然子茶作りましょうねよじゃよ
胸だった
スポってうっはっはーヨイショ
入ってあげて全部5は箱から出してどうぞあとでぜんぶに求めて言ってる打ち込みは
マゾほとんどんおばあちゃんを入れていきます
えっ
あっはぁあああああ
[音楽]
surfer こっちが浮き今さん鳥だったら酒に湯切りします
かけてほしい
あっ一尾ずつ予測アイス2
入って読みだよなんとかできました
プレゼンてっ
レペゼンて全然店電源店で電源前提で売れる
バンパ
[音楽]
行くからの方だなんとも言えんわねんぞ何とも言えないから行かないっ
こっちは美味しいつに美味しい
なんかで場所によって全然味が違うんですよねるこっから
味道超えて食べると食べないかのうん働いております
ないんだよねうっ
[音楽]
もうちょっと食べるしてあーっネットっ
ビッ
[音楽]
きゅんっ
おっ
ん
増えてねー
いるじゃろ
ほい前だろちょっと伸び始めば20
[音楽]
よっしゃーそうだっですっ
よし感触ですいやあああっああまあ美味しかったでしょ
最初だけ見て選手最初だけは確かやっぱ量的な問題がありましたね
という感触でございますはい我々はいち早くぴ&の復活を心よりお待ちしております
よろしくお願いします
小座間車
[音楽]